the death toll in Israel soared above
700 on
Sunday a number likely to numb much of
Israeli
Society many of those killed close to
Gaza had come to
dance but as Hamas Fighters attacked
crowds of ravers ran for their
lives many were dragged into Gaza as
captives in the face of this Onslaught
Israel's military is facing criticism
for its slow response on Saturday
morning by Sunday morning its war planes
smashing the strip with near constant
air
strikes Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu has promised to turn Gaza into
an island of
ruins for some residents that
Devastation already a reality with GS
and health authorities reporting many
hundreds killed in Israeli attacks
Israel says this destruction is just the
start of a long response to hamas's
unprecedented
attack tanks and Munitions also massing
by the border with Lebanon following
artillery and Rocket fire back and forth
with Hezbollah to the
north large numbers of soldiers are
mobilizing in the now militarize Zone
near Gaza with a warning to Palestinian
civilians to back away from the boundary
Lin that Hamas had
breached there are tens of thousands of
military personnel in the surrounding
areas near Gaza we will continue to
arrive to every settlement until we kill
all the gunmen who are inside Israeli
territory in the occupied West Bank
mourning for several civilians killed in
clashes with security
forces among them a mother torn by grief
for a teenage
son several countries have called for
the violence to cease but no sign either
side will contemplate a cessation
anytime soon vill marks Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer